so i want to start today with the
vaccination and the delta variant and
some really really ignorant stuff
continuing to come out of i mean i guess
we have to call it the
at least tacitly anti-vaxx media um
fox hosts on fox and friends can't
understand
why president joe biden is so focused on
getting americans vaccinated and on
getting vaccines
to people around the world in other
countries now last week i did a segment
where
i explained i really hate politics
not because i lack passion about the
issues but because so much of our time
has to be spent preventing really
ignorant people
bad people in some cases from actively
doing damage to the country
and here is a perfect example of this
right now we are engaged
in a battle against a virus and a highly
contagious delta variant
and against anti-vaxxers as well to
truly end this pandemic we're not just
fighting the virus
we're fighting the anti-vaxxers as well
the so-called coveted truthers
unfortunately some countries do not yet
have enough vaccines that's a very
specific problem
but just as unfortunately we do have
enough vaccines
but we have a huge portion of our
population in the u.s that just doesn't
want one
and our ability to defeat this pandemic
now comes down
so simply i mean it couldn't be any
simpler
just get vaccinated vaccinate as quickly
as possible
and on fox news their minds are just
boggled by joe biden working
really proactively on vaccination why
won't he stop working on vaccination
take a look at this meanwhile sedmon
says at the top of the hour they're one
of the big stories
been with us the last two years is
covered 19. the origin is the top story
but the but the focus of this
administration on vaccination
is uh mind boggling listen in many cases
they've done a very good job getting the
word out
and getting the vaccine out from johnson
johnson to pfizer to moderna
they're available if you want them but
that's not enough now you need to be
berated by none other than dr
fauci because you're playing politics
that's the reason
you may have not gotten it listen
this is not complicated we're not asking
anybody to make any political statement
one way or another
we're saying try and save your life and
that of your family and that of the
community
it's mind-boggling guys and look at
brian kilmeade even saying
you know some people might not want to
get vaccinated
because they're being encouraged if you
just left them alone is the implication
maybe they would go and get themselves
vaccinated it's it's like an insanely
childish reverse psychology to get
people vaccinated to save their own
lives or the lives of people they love
or people in their communities you have
to go to the childish
oh you can't have this little jimmy oh
really oh i want it then give me the
thing you're telling me i can't have
and this is why things are now looking
so rough
i can't believe this is happening but
cases are going way up
here in the united states i i cases are
up almost 50 percent
50 percent cases are up in the last 10
days
in spain spain really had this under
control
cases are up 360. percent
measures are quickly being put back in
place
in the united kingdom that's one of the
spot's earliest hit by the delta variant
daily cases are up 1400 percent now of
course
the good news depending on your
perspective is that
it's mostly unvaccinated people that are
getting infected right now
now you might say well that's good news
in the sense that it means the vaccines
work well
the problem is not everybody can get
vaccinated yet in some countries because
they don't yet have vaccines in some
countries because they're too young to
qualify
uh but but that's not that's not
everybody right i mean six to eight
percent of people of normal health
will get a vaccine and not develop
immunity and
there are breakthrough cases more and
more of them are the delta variant
and some of those vaccinated people are
going to get hit as well
and in the meantime as cases are up 50
percent
in the united states fox news can't
figure out
why is so biden so focused on
vaccination as if it's a bad thing
we are really in trouble as a country
and i don't expect this to get any
better they seem to be digging in
and forget about delta we're soon going
to have lambda
i don't even want to guess at this point
i'm not even going to think about it yet
what things are going to look like in
the united states in the fall
one of our sponsors today is strategic
voters a new podcast that features
election experts political campaign
strategists and everyday americans
who sit down and discuss the biggest
issues in the u.s
political landscape on the activism side
strategic voters as an organization
aims to encourage people to vote with
the benefit of the country
as a whole in mind instead of just
voting one party
down the ballot if you want to hear some
really different
and interesting opinions and approaches
to voting and viewing policies
give the strategic voters podcast a
listen
the latest two episodes feature rachel
cobb and lana atkinson as guests
i've been listening to it myself i've
been really enjoying it it's very
grassroots and independent which i love
find the strategic voters podcast
on all major podcast platforms and make
sure to follow them on twitter
at strategic voters